[Musique]
allez rose bonjour on y va allez on se
dépêche
[Musique]
justement
on peut peut-être l'aider non
alors on y va on se met bien droit
les mains posées sur les genoux les
pieds bien ancrés au sol et on ferme les
yeux
on arrête de parler on ferme les yeux on
essaie d'être en silence
vous détendez
vous respirez bien profondément vous
sentez bien votre respiration
il peut y avoir des images qui arrivent
aussi il peut y avoir des couleurs
s'il y a des pensées qui arrivent vous
les laissez passer vous les observez
sont là elles passent
j'ai l'impression d'être un bourgeon
mais qui rend mal de travers
ça me fait toujours ça j'ai toujours
l'impression que j'ai pas d'âge votre
prénom que je suis pas quelqu'un mais je
suis quelque chose qui passe à travers
le temps ou
je sais pas il y a des moments où ça
m'arrive où je
traverse tout et j'ai
je suis quelque part autre part que
maintenant là où je suis je suis dans un
autre monde je suis parti
vous êtes apaisé vous sentez le calme
qui vient en vous
j'aime pas méditer parce que ça m'en
stressé quand je ferme les yeux je vois
tout du noir et après ça me fait penser
à des jeux d'horreur et après ça me
déconcentre
parfois les images
restent ensemble on a une fille qui
s'appelle Maya
et après je suis timide et je vais
directement les yeux
moi j'aime bien penser et c'est vrai que
quand je pense bah je passe du coca là
je sais que Thomas il est amoureux de
moi
des fois j'hésite en lui disant des
choses parce que j'ai pas envie de le
blesser
dès que vous sentez que vous partez dans
les pensées vous revenez à la
respiration
je suis dans la forêt j'ai vu le loup et
il a voulu chanter sur moi je vais
monter mes dents et je le mordais je le
mordais je le mordais je le mordais je
vais lâcher même pas après les parties
vous allez ouvrir les yeux
progressivement chacun son rythme
alors votre Maître Olivier vous a
expliqué ce que je viens faire voilà je
vais faire plusieurs fois avec vous des
ateliers de philosophie de méditation
parce que moi vous savez j'ai appris la
philo j'étais très jeune aussi et ça m'a
énormément aidé ça m'a aidé à apprendre
à discerner apprendre à juger à
réfléchir parce que on reçoit tous dans
nos familles dans la société un tas
d'information et souvent on n'a pas
d'esprit critique par rapport à ça et il
y a un philosophe qui s'appelle
Montaigne il disait à l'école on nous
apprend à voir une tête bien pleine
c'est-à-dire qu'on apprend beaucoup de
connaissances et il disait il faudrait
nous apprendre aussi à avoir une tête
bien faite c'est à dire apprendre à bien
penser et parmi les sujets dont parle
beaucoup puis on dit beaucoup de bêtises
dessus c'est l'action de la religion
alors je vous pose la question c'est
quoi une religion à quoi ça sert une
religion et là on n'est pas dans
l'émotion on réfléchit pour donner des
arguments Mamadou
ça veut dire quoi
les légendes comme Hercule les mythes
ouais les mythes moi je crois que c'est
la mythologie qui est euh
Gorka moi je crois que c'est quand on
était plutôt à des singes assez évolué
mais pas encore des Homo sapiens on se
disait
on se posait des questions mais comment
comment il y a pu y avoir un monde comme
ça il y a bien une raison c'est pas
intéressant
au monde c'est ça et des fois je me dis
je saurais pas imaginer qu'il est
quelque chose qui qui peut créer des
planètes et des galaxies entières
toutes les questions sans réponse ça te
dit il y a forcément une réponse c'est
Dieu
mais il y a des personnes qui croient ça
moi je sais pas après d'accord c'est
très clair rose je pense qu'on en a
besoin mais ça entraîne aussi des
guerres c'est que les religions
entraînent de la violence et des guerres
Jérémy qu'est-ce que tu voulais dire
ceux qui sont musulmans ceux qu'on fasse
en fait ils essayent de déclarer des
guerres
j'ai 10 ans
je pratique la religion
avant j'étais à thé mais maintenant je
fais la prière tout seul
je réfléchis
quand je vais mourir qu'est-ce qui va se
passer
en fait quand j'étais en maternelle ça
faisait pas dormir donc après je dors
mal à l'école
et quand
j'ai commencé à savoir que
je commence à y croire et
ça
m'a plu fait penser à ça
mais après comme du dieu c'est dans le
ciel on voit le ciel Dieu
[Musique]
j'aime pas ça aussi parce que
après tu es plus proche de la mort tu te
rapproche de plus en plus de la mort
en philosophie par exemple je réfléchis
[Musique]
pourquoi la morale existe
pourquoi elle me dit
peut-être que ça serait
[Musique]
pour mettre un terme à toutes nos
souffrances
façon tout à une fin
juste un tour de piste et après bah
c'est fini
pour moi c'est ça
parce que tout est une fin
rien
[Musique]
je suis convaincu que si on faisait des
ateliers de méditation et philosophie
dans toutes les écoles du monde le monde
changerait en une génération
[Musique]
ce qu'on aurait des gens qui seraient
capables de gérer leurs émotions et qui
serait capable de discerner d'avoir un
esprit critique de ne pas se laisser
emprunter dans toutes les idéologies
politiques religieuses consuméristes qui
sont en train de détruire la planète
c'est l'éducation qui est la clé de tout
[Musique]
j'étais frappé de voir j'ai fait des
ateliers de philosophie avec des enfants
dans des cultures complètement
différentes j'ai été à Abidjan j'étais à
Pointe-à-Pitre j'étais à Genève Paris en
Corse dans des villages dans des grandes
villes dans des milieux pauvres dans des
milieux riches et chaque fois on
retrouve par la philosophie finalement
une sorte
d'universalité de la pensée
[Musique]
on peut être bouddhiste musulman chinois
hindous chrétiens athée et se mettent
d'accord sur des raisonnements
fondamentaux parce qu'on a la même
raison la raison est universelle
bonjour Frédéric bonjour Nora
la bienvenue merci
[Musique]
pour vous les grandes questions vous
vous posez sur la vie
maquillage je suis pas certain un
philosophe qui te répondra à ça c'est
une bonne question alors ouais
à quoi ça sert de faire des cauchemars
ça on peut le noter Benamar pourquoi on
est comme ça
pourquoi on est comme ça c'est qu'est-ce
que tu veux dire exactement
exactement je veux dire pourquoi on
existe pourquoi on existe Lorenzo
pourquoi on meurt voilà une très belle
question philosophique on va commencer
par ça alors ouais
meurt parce que il y a beaucoup de
personnes qui font des enfants
et des enfants
et ben on doit
leur laisser la place parce que sinon la
terre elle lui aura pas assez de place
pour que tout le monde puisse aller à
l'intérieur vous êtes d'accord avec ça
alors est-ce que vous pensez qu'il vaut
mieux être mortel ou immortel vous allez
lever la main ce qui disent qu'il vaut
mieux être mortel que c'est mieux d'être
mortel
oui et quels sont ceux qui pensent qu'il
vaut mieux être immortel bon c'est à peu
près les trois quarts
alors Aya est-ce que tu penses que pour
toi la raison principale de vivre c'est
de manger et dormir
là il y a un débat
Tom on va à l'école et après
on mange après on dort et après on
remarche etc
essayez de dire qu'est-ce qui est le
plus important pour vous Anaïs moi c'est
ma famille c'est ta famille donc le plus
important dans la vie c'est la famille
et pourquoi
ça nous fait de la peine
de la vie c'est que que c'est que on
s'entend
c'est de bien s'entendre donc c'est la
relation avec les autres le plus
important
de regarder la télé toute la nuit
donc toi on est sur terre pour manger
dormir et regarder la télévision c'est
ça
alors qui n'est pas d'accord avec elle
moi je suis d'accord avec Aya parce que
en fait
par exemple mon père il rentre à la
maison il mange après il regarde la télé
et après comme on le voit le matin
allongé sur le canapé
en train de manger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Anaïs
moi le plus important c'est d'être
vivante le plus important c'est d'être
vivant est-ce que le fait c'est le seul
fait d'être vivant ça te rend heureuse
au début je mets je me disais que tu
étais du sport à la philosophie
c'est pas possible je me suis trompé
moi-même
bah là j'ai
7 ans et demi
j'ai besoin de moins en moins la joie
je
[Musique]
sens que c'est très compliqué à faire ce
que je pense
je sais pas ce qui peut se passer
dans ce que je vais devenir
c'est trop sophistiqué pour moi la vie
ou je sais pas
franchement
la boule elle est dans mes pensées elle
reflète tout au passé
là je pense
[Musique]
que le moment où je me fais une
cicatrice
[Musique]
le moment
de mon anniversaire
et on voit tout le passé pour moi c'est
ça me sert beaucoup
[Musique]
la religion mais je sais pas si c'est
vraiment réel
c'est-à-dire en fait je crois mais je
sais pas si
ça existe
je crois mais je ne le sais pas mais je
crois je confirme c'est juste pour pas
faire des cauchemars et pour pas aller
en enfer
quand j'étais petit je croyais que le
paradis c'était un énorme château en or
où il y avait des PlayStation en or des
téléphones en or je ne crois pas que
c'est ça mais moi je crois le paradis
c'est un rêve c'est ça je crois ou sinon
je me trompe l'enfer mais de l'enfer je
crois il existe l'enfer c'est la
pollution en fait
c'est c'est les terroristes l'enfer il
est déjà sur la terre
et j'ai pas du tout peur de la mort
c'est le futur qui réserve ça j'ai pas
envie que je gâche la surprise
c'est le cercle de la vie tout le monde
doit mourir
moi oui j'ai peur de la mort parce que
c'est vrai que je crois en Dieu mais
j'ai pas de preuve
rose peut-être que
penser qu'il y a un paradis après ça
fait du bien parce que peut-être qu'on a
des regrets dans notre vie et que en
ayant une deuxième vie on peut
[Musique]
je sais pas comment dire on peut réparer
ce qu'on a pas bien fait dans cette vie
Janie
parce que les chats ils font comme nous
ou tous les à peu près tous les animaux
et bah ils font comme nous ils voient
ils mangent ils prennent leur douche ils
font tout tout comme nous et je pense
que ils ont déjà eu une leur deuxième
vie si tu penses que les animaux comme
les êtres humains se réincarnent Maya tu
as rien dit tu as peur de la mort ou pas
toi
est-ce que je peux mourir maintenant ou
pas et du coup je réfléchis et ce que je
trouve le plus horrible dans la mort
c'est de plus penser parce que moi
j'aime bien penser
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
moi j'ai pas peur de la mort comme ça
soudaine mais de la mort on a trans
souffrant ou tu as mal ou tu as peur
tu es tellement surprise tu es choqué
t'es voilà ça j'ai ça j'ai peur mais la
mort en elle-même non pas spécialement
et même c'est amusant de savoir ce qui
aurait après et d'imaginer surtout
comme j'étais petite je voulais
absolument absolument grandir maintenant
je suis pas grandir je veux rester comme
petit
je suis bien je n'ai pas envie de
grandir
[Musique]
je suis mieux petit
ça fait bizarre de grandir j'avais passé
tout un été dans une maison de campagne
où il y avait pas de miroir je suis
revenu genre deux mois plus tard j'avais
grandi j'étais là c'est pas moi c'est
pas moi
quand tu es enfant tu sais pas ce que tu
vas devenir et tu changes tout le temps
quand tu es grand bah tu es devenu
personne et tu sais qui tu es
moi je suis tout le monde est personne
et
j'ai beaucoup posé la question bah je
vois rien
rien du tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez mettre votre attention sur
votre respiration
soyez attentif à ce que vous ressentez
s'il y a des idées qui viennent des
pensées vous les laissez passer vous les
suivez pas et vous revenez à la présence
de votre corps
maintenant vous prenez une grande
respiration
et vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux chacun à
votre rythme quand vous avez envie
d'ouvrir les yeux vous ouvrez les yeux
tu commences à t'endormir
moi j'ai ressenti que
l'imagination et j'ai vu des carrés qui
passaient devant moi
à la fin
est-ce que tu as faim
moi quand je quand on m'énerve j'arrive
même pas j'arrive pas à me calmer
tu as du mal à gérer tes colères est-ce
qu'on a d'autres ici qui ont du mal à
gérer leurs colères aussi lever la main
oui beaucoup hein est-ce qu'il y en a
d'autres qui ont du mal à gérer leur
peur
vous savez ce que c'est que les émotions
l'amour alors maintenant mais c'est
intéressant ce que tu dis l'amour ça
peut être effectivement une émotion
parce que une émotion c'est quoi
exactement
en fait une émotion c'est quelque chose
aussi qu'on peut pas on peut pas s'en
empêcher de le faire c'est quelque chose
qui s'impose à toi on n'est pas libre
face à une émotion c'est ça que tu veux
dire
des fois
alors est-ce qu'on peut arriver à
maîtriser une émotion est-ce que des
fois qu'on est en colère on fait des
choses qu'on voudrait pas faire oui par
exemple
elle vient
et je les Condé alors que je voulais pas
la gronder donc du coup des fois on va
s'accrocher avec ce qu'on aime parce
qu'on est en colère et après on regrette
c'est ça que tu dis
c'est vrai qu'il y a des fois on fait
des choses qu'on n'a pas envie de faire
on sait qu'on doit pas les faire mais on
les fait quand même parce qu'on est pris
dans une émotion et il y a un grand
philosophe qui s'appelle Spinoza qui a
dit que des fois on esclave de ses peurs
on est esclave de ses colères on est
esclave de ces tristesse qui nous
empêchent de d'être nous-mêmes et de
faire ce qu'on voudrait vraiment faire
donc vous voyez la liberté c'est aussi
se libérer de l'esclavage de nos
émotions c'est pour ça qu'on fait de la
philosophie
stop
au niveau des émotions il y en a une
autre c'est laquelle la sérénité la
sérénité c'est quoi la sérénité
[Musique]
les enfants
c'est pas mal
[Musique]
dans la musique par exemple
ben ça m'aide
dans
par exemple enfin je fais tantôt il faut
faire ton tonton
et je vais faire des par exemple je
pense à une note je pense à faire ça
et je peux faire
et du coup
ça m'aide à faire des chansons et du
coup après
je trouve la version qui me plaît sinon
je le garde tout le temps
j'aime bien les sous ce que je fais
quand je crée des choses
c'est pour c'est pas que pour faire
plaisir aux autres c'est pour me faire
plaisir à moi aussi
[Musique]
j'y crois vraiment
que je crois qu'on je crois bien qu'on
pourrait y arriver à faire quoi
il faut vraiment s'y mettre
j'aime bien être en vie
tout cas la seule question enfin c'est
pas qu'une question mais comment ça se
fait que j'ai autant de chance je sais
pas comment ça se fait
il est où la peur elle est où la peur la
peur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je crois j'ai trouvé
par l'enversité
attends on peut trouver la peur la peur
la peur la peur la peur l'émotion que
l'on ressent en face d'un danger ou
d'une menace
[Musique]
a peur des chiens l'orage lui fait peur
mais pas peur ne t'inquiète pas et ça va
[Musique]
et toi tu as peur
du temps
[Musique]
et après
5 jours sont tes parents ça te fait
grandir parce que moi
oui ça fait pour moi ça fait grandir
dans la tête ça fait
enlever la peur
c'est juste une imagination on croit
qu'on m'agrandit mais les autres ils
croient qu'on a grandi mais en fait on a
pas grandi c'est juste une imagination
mais moi je parle dans ta tête des fois
je me sens
quelle ville au Cameroun
Yaoundé c'était difficile de partir du
Cameroun pour revenir
en France
pleurer
ta famille là-bas
moi je suis moi j'ai pleuré hier parce
que ma mamie elle était morte hier au
Maroc
mon papa il est parti là-bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi on nous fait vivre et après on
meurt
et la question que je me pose
pourquoi
on nous fait vivre et pourquoi on reste
pas tout le temps sur terre
quand on est mort on n'a pas peur de
mourir
bah en fait mon papa il est mort j'avais
trois ans
est-ce que toi mon papa il est mort
j'étais très triste comme papa il est
mort mais après j'ai parlé aux adultes
et ça m'a aidé à
me calmer et
même mes copines ils m'ont aidé à
être moins timide et à être courageuse
et après ben j'ai mon troisième adulte
pas moi
des fois quand je suis quand j'arrive
pas à dire quelque chose que je suis
embêté mais moi je fais ça mais enfin je
respire un grand coup
et si on me dit
oui ok
et bah moi je respire et des fois dans
ma chambre il va je fais de la
philosophie et je parle toute seule à
mon papa
j'en fais souvent parce que je pleure
souvent
ça marche très bien
et moi en fait
et ben quand je marche je rêve aussi que
mon papa il est en train de parler avec
quelqu'un dans le ciel et qui me regarde
il se dit qu'il est fier de moi
et que
je resterai quand même dans son cœur
moi j'aime la vie
une fois j'étais avec mes amis on
rigolait bien et je pensais même plus à
mon papa du coup là je trouvais que
c'était un moment trop bien
[Musique]
chéri
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc on va faire l'atelier philo c'est
une question philosophique mais c'est
une question qu'on se pose très souvent
dans la vie alors doit-on toujours dire
la vérité qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
au tuner par exemple c'est sûr que je
vais pas le dire c'est vrai que ça
arrive tous les matins quelqu'un va se
faire guillotiner alors non tu veux dire
si quelqu'un va mourir faut pas lui dire
c'est ça que tu veux dire et pourquoi
faut pas lui dire parce qu'après bah
elle va stresser elle va se suicider
avant de mourir donc tu veux dire pour
pour la préserver ça veut dire d'accord
juste Mamadou tu as dit à l'instant
c'est bête ça tu vois non et alors
Mamadou faut pas faire ce genre de
réflexion parce que tout ce qui est dit
ici est intéressant les choses font pas
forcément bêtes tu peux ne pas être
d'accord tu vois tu peux dire je suis
pas d'accord ça veut pas dire que c'est
bête donc dit je suis pas d'accord ok
t'es pas d'accord pourquoi parce que
[Musique]
grandir faut que tu disais la vérité
parce que c'est mieux de dire la vérité
que de garder la chose donc je suis pas
d'accord avec toi réfléchissez
bah tu vas profiter de toute ta vie tu
vas faire la fiesta si tu fais la fête
comme ça il te reste encore une minute à
vivre bah bah la pire chose que tu la
pire lui dise que tu veux faire toute ta
vie
tu feras une moto cross tu fonces sur
une piste tu penses et il te reste 2
secondes 2 1 tu saute dans une SARC
enflammée
tu réalises ton fantasme suprême Binta
je suis désolé Kalilou mais c'est
surréaliste il peut pas triste une
minute à vivre il te reste au moins un
mois un an ou même une semaine je me
parlez pas tous en même temps levez la
main ceux qui veulent parler je vous
pose la question alors les bonnes
raisons vous l'avez un peu dit qu'est-ce
qui serait une mauvaise raison de mentir
pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut mentir pour
des mauvaises raisons Diani
un soir j'avais des devoirs faire et
j'avais oublié mon père il me dit que tu
as fait des devoirs je dis oui et à la
fin il ouvre la porte de l'entrée et il
me voit faire mes devoirs
et donc après il a rien dit
il est rien dit c'est-à-dire qu'il a su
que tu avais menti
et depuis tu m'as plus jamais
je n'ai pas le droit de
etc puis elle l'a mis dans une valise
une grosse valise c'était super lourd
elle est partie dans le métro et après
un moment il y a un garçon qui fait ah
ouais je peux vous aider mais le métro
elle est partie réelle
merci après c'est lourd qu'est-ce que
vous avez dedans elle peut pas répondre
bah il y a mon chien mort qui est mort
il y a les platines de mon frère il fait
ah à peu près il a pris la valise il a
sauté dans le métro le métro est parti
et il a volé la valise et du coup elle
s'est dit tu vois comment elle va ouvrir
la valise
donc il vaut mieux mentir qu'on a un
cadavre dans une valise
oui c'est vrai c'est vraiment pas cher
le plus drôle en fait exprès mon père il
avait retiré un billet de 500
voilà c'était c'était 20 et moi je suis
parti prendre le billet de 20 ans son
porte-monnaie je suis parti mettre ça à
la poubelle et après ma mère elle est
partie mettre à la poubelle et au moment
où on peut mon père il m'a dit il est où
le pied devant j'ai fait c'est pas moi
donc comme ma mère elle savait pas après
maman ma mère elle m'avait vu elle a dit
c'est lui qui a pris le billet de 20 et
de la mets à la poubelle aide mais mon
père il a couru là dessus la poubelle
mais non mais au tout début elle savait
pas au tout début elle savait pas alors
elle a pas de voix
ma grande sœur elle ma grande sœur elle
est pas réaliste j'ai dit d'abord ta
mère elle le dit ta mère elle le dit
puis ensuite ta sœur c'est la sœur qui
qui dit à ta mère que que en fait mais
c'est pas réaliste
je rappelle quand même le sujet qui est
doit-on dire la vérité et en fait il y
en a plein qui racontent des choses
complètement farfelues et certainement
inventé et on s'éloigne pas du tout du
sujet finalement je trouve ça quand même
fabuleux alors qu'on parle de vérité ce
qui est juste intéressant c'est que vous
avez tendance des fois oublier certaines
choses il y a eu des signatures de
parents imités ou des pages où il y
avait des mots sur le carré
correspondance arraché et de toute façon
un moment donné vous avez remarqué ça se
retourne toujours contre vous
dans mon cahier j'ai fait ça signature
c'est juste un petit commentaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
viens
Kalilou et Gorka vous faites passer
d'abord Jérémy par le bureau du
directeur pour expliquer ce qui s'est
passé et après il va en classe d'accueil
allez hop
[Applaudissements]
c'est un peu plus comme ça il tombera
mais il est tombé mais il sait pas la
prochaine fois qu'il le fasse mieux
Jérémy comme ça il tombera
les règles tu vas les comprendre quand
Jérémy
j'entends pas maintenant
le 8 mars
accueil s'il vous plaît merci
tout le monde ne respecte pas les règles
les règles c'est quelque chose que tu as
le droit de faire et tu as pas le droit
de faire
moi mon rêve
de tête ou de qui j'ai de l'argent qui
soit riche voilà
moi je voudrais qu'il y ait plus
d'argent dans ce monde tout sera gratuit
parce que tout est payant dans le monde
sauf la livraison de chez Amazon premium
parce que la largeur après c'est une
sorte de chantage
parce que
c'est comme de l'esclavage en fait on
dit faire quelque chose pour gagner de
l'argent
alors que le président lui fait que de
dire des règles pour gagner 8000 € par
mois c'est beaucoup
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien le président comme ça je
gagne après l'argent
[Musique]
et toi
alors on va refaire un atelier philo
ensemble aujourd'hui le thème c'est
comment est-ce qu'on sait qu'il y a des
choses qu'on doit faire et des choses
qu'on doit pas faire comment est-ce
qu'on sait qu'il y a des actions qui
sont bonnes et qui a des actions qui
sont mauvaises Adam
tu la frappes pas bah dis donc
tu es sûr
et toi il y a quelqu'un qui te frappe
quand tu écoutes pas
ta sœur
utiliser la raison pour lui demander
où tu dois faire ou tu dois pas faire
c'est peut-être mieux non qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez d'utiliser la raison que
de frapper donc qu'est-ce que tu en
penses je préfère frapper pourquoi tu
préfères frapper
tu veux dire que quand tu donnes des
raisons et l'écoute pas c'est ça et
quand tu frappes
à l'écouter tu es sûr qu'elle a vraiment
compris
elle comprendrait mieux pour ne pas
refaire la même chose la prochaine fois
qu'est-ce que tu en penses
que moi je demandais à ma mère si mon
frère il peut arrêter de toucher à mes
affaires ma mère elle s'en fiche donc
avoir regardé ses séries après arrêt
comme moi comment je prends sa tête
comme ça et je le colle sur le mur il
fait ok j'arrête j'arrête j'arrête en
pleurant et après s'il y a pas d'adultes
mais c'est normal aussi qu'on frappe les
autres
pour taper parce que moi comme mon frère
il touchait à quelque chose et je lui
dis de pas toucher bah il le touche à la
fois je fais semblant de le taper et
après il dit non
sérieusement si tu fais une bêtise tu
préfères qu'on t'explique les choses que
des adultes expliquent les choses faut
pas que tu recommences ou tu préfères
qui te tape
honnêtement
je te pose une question
donc pour toi tu préfères qui t'explique
que plutôt qui te tape alors pourquoi tu
tapes les autres plutôt de leur
expliquer
parce que mon frère il continue
et
tu as bien expliqué
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est idéal
d'être obligé de frapper les gens pour
qu'ils comprennent les choses ou qui a
une meilleure solution c'est quoi la
meilleure solution oui ouais
on a un pistolet et on veut tirer on
peut tuer
des gens en faisant ça et on peut le
savoir de nous-même on pourrait savoir
que c'est pas bien tu sais où elle qui a
un grand philosophe qui s'appelle
Emmanuel Kant qui a vécu il y a
plusieurs siècles et dit la même chose
que toi il dit que la loi morale elle
est inscrite en nous dans notre raison
dans notre conscience et qu'on sait
qu'on ne doit pas tuer quelqu'un qu'on
ne doit pas voler qu'on doit pas mentir
etc et ça c'est ce que tu dis c'est que
il y a des choses on sait qu'on doit pas
les faire
[Musique]
ils nous ont surpris comme d'habitude en
disant des choses qu'on a pas envie
qu'ils disent à savoir finalement il
faut taper
ça c'est sûr que on n'a pas envie
d'entendre ça mais leur dire faut pas le
faire c'est pas bien ça sert à rien
c'est les bêtises que je pouvais faire
peut-être en début au début quand
j'essayais de faire de la philo sans
savoir
comment faire et ben effectivement
c'était j'avais plutôt tendance à leur
dire mais non ça a pensé comme ça
et voilà donc je guidais leur réflexion
et c'était complètement stérile et
l'idée c'est que peut-être que le
questionnement qu'on a eu la même si on
a rien tranché on l'aura pas dit bah
c'est bien ou c'est mal ça va peut-être
les amener à réfléchir à leurs actes
il y a pas de mode d'emploi il y a juste
une interrogation qui fait que on amène
la personne finalement à se poser des
questions et à s'interroger sur ses
comportements ses attitudes ses émotions
et c'est comme ça finalement l'éducation
fonctionne le mieux
moi je crois que la philosophie nous
permet de résister
je pense vraiment que tout relève de la
capacité des individus à résister
individuellement un système qui est
pervers et aujourd'hui on a plusieurs
propositions de société qui à mon avis
sont désastreuses qu'elles soient dans
l'idéologie religieuse ou qu'elle soit
en consumériste il faut que les
individus soient capables de résister à
ça je pense qu'aux États-Unis Trump n'a
pas été élu par la raison il a été élu
par la peur et la colère de certains
Américains et donc finalement la
démocratie a besoin aussi que les
individus fassent un travail sur
eux-mêmes c'est parce qu'il y aura de
plus en plus d'individus éclairés
éveillés conscient lucide résistant que
le collectif va se transformer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout le monde est là allez un grand
cercle
moi une petite place
allez allez allez allez
[Applaudissements]
et on y va on y va on y va
plus doucement doucement on y va et
3 4
[Musique]
est-ce que ça fait ça dis-moi
deux trois ok attention et ton prénom
on y va trois quatre
magnifique on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de plus important c'est des trucs tous
tous tous heureux et tous avoir une
famille et une maison
mais parfois elle est grand il ne
respecte pas les règles
bonjour Maman
tu vas bien
[Musique]
on a mangé
on a joué on a pris une chanson mais on
a on a perdu du temps
et c'est terminé
[Musique]
mon petit frère il dort là
moi je dors là mes parents
[Musique]
on peut jouer
le philosophie c'est qu'on respecte la
règle et que on se raconte la vie de de
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire de qu'est-ce
qu'on doit pas faire
ça peut aider à changer le monde
parfois il y a des gens qui sont pas de
maison
et à cause de ça ils sont là-bas ils
sont là-bas et ils dorment il dort par
terre mais ça c'est pas bien il faut que
ça change un petit peu
[Musique]
on va commencer par un petit travail de
théâtre d'improvisation sur les thèmes
de philosophie qu'on aura travaillé
cette année avec Frédéric
donc vous allez vous mettre par deux
vous aurez deux minutes pour le préparer
dehors
2 minutes pour passer sur scène
alors
l'amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça dépend ça pour rendre heureux et
parfois ça peut rendre triste et quand
tombe amoureux qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce qu'on ressent
[Musique]
IR cette personne il fallait
mais t'es pas à l'âge de te marier Naila
tu as déjà été amoureuse
tu es tombé amoureux de quelqu'un déjà
oui et à ce moment-là qu'est-ce que tu
as ressenti comme émotion comme
sensation
rien
ici l'amour ça peut faire mal au cœur
parce qu'on peut séparer ça peut briser
et après on veut plus sortir de chez
nous on veut plus voir de couleur bah
c'est un peu dommage moi je tomberai pas
amoureux moi je veux pas mais est-ce que
tu as déjà été amoureuse mais tu veux
pas parce que tu as peur d'être
malheureuse
la peur par exemple si
tu as peur d'avoir des enfants
si tu veux pas avoir d'enfant
aussi il y a la couleur parce que il m'a
colère oui parce que des fois il y a
deux personnes qui sont amoureux mais il
se disputent mais ça change rien tu veux
dire que quand on est amoureux on se
dispute souvent
être amoureuse c'est dur c'est dur qui
est-ce qui veut répondre à cette
question oui Gabriel c'est dur de
trouver un mari ou une femme mais si tu
veux trouver et si tu veux pas
rencontrer batacad envoyer un message ou
être sur Facebook pour en trouver un bah
c'est vrai sur Facebook
je suis d'accord avec Benamar c'est dur
parce que après tu te faut se rendre
compte que pour faire un bébé ça fait
mal il faut beaucoup d'amour pour le cri
la différence entre un amoureux et un
ami les amis c'est
comme si
explique-moi par exemple
[Musique]
tu es pauvre et ça a mis ben c'est
presque pareil sans amis tes pauvre mais
ami imagine il y a quelqu'un qui ton ami
te trahi mais tu le sais pas et après à
la fin tu le sais tu vas tu vas plus
jamais lui parler enfin quand un truc
comme ça
vous avez peur que les amis vous
trahissent comme vous avez peur que les
amoureux vous trahissent que de peur
allez on va la récré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ben dis donc
c'était surprenant je sais pas si tu as
été aussi surpris que moi le côté noir
qui est la manière dont sombre oui tu as
ressenti la même chose c'était frappant
et je pense que moi le fait comme ça
d'avoir un débat sur les sentiments sur
ce qui ressentent intérieurement et de
sa percevoir que d'autres partages la
même expérience ça peut aussi libérer de
quelque chose
Gabriel c'est typiquement je trouve
qu'elle a un mélange d'attente et en
même temps et ben on parle de toi
justement
parce que tu as beaucoup parlé on
sentait que c'est un sujet que tu avais
passionné
tu connais tout en amour
[Musique]
je fais des rêves très jolie
je me disais
je me disais si c'était vraiment
possible que
[Musique]
si c'était vraiment possible de que
que
[Musique]
en fait dans mon rêve
je suis à la cantine elle se met à côté
de moi
après comme c'est embrouillé les rêves
quand je dors elle me sert dans les bras
après elle revient je sais pas quoi et
aussi j'ai le rêve ou Maya elle dort
chez moi
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé sur manteau et je l'ai serré
dans les bras c'était aujourd'hui oui
c'était aujourd'hui et c'était comme
dans mon rêve il était doux comme dans
mon rêve
[Musique]
l'amour j'ai jamais d'amour et je le
sais pas parce que j'ai jamais compris
ce que c'était en fait
parce que on m'a déjà expliqué plein de
fois mais c'est quand tu aimes la
personne t'as pas envie qu'elle quand
elle est pas là tu as envie qu'elle soit
là avec toi qu'elle te manque souvent
mais moi ça m'est jamais arrivé et du
coup des fois on me raconte plein
d'histoires mais je suis persuadée que
les gens ils ressemblent pas ça
c'est vrai que j'ai pas vraiment
confiance en moi mais je sais toujours
pas pourquoi
j'ai découvert que j'aimerais avoir une
fille des fois et que je l'aurais
probablement jamais
parce que j'ai peut-être pas les chances
pour la voir cette vidéo
[Musique]
j'ai pas les capacités les qualités ou
bien les défauts et moi j'ai justement
très peur de venir un peu comme ces
adolescents qui ont des
qui sont en dépression qui ont des
problèmes et du coup ils se referment
sur
vous écrivez
mon journal intime philosophique
d'accord
je suis très pessimiste ma sœur m'a dit
que dans la famille on était tousimé
d'après elle être pessimiste c'est être
réaliste du coup bah je suis pessimiste
et très paranoïaque donc le mélange des
deux est parfait pour être dépressif
mais je ne le suis pas
les ateliers philo ça me rapporte encore
plus de réfléchir les parents des fois
ils me disent mais Maya tu réfléchis
beaucoup trop mais moi je trouve que
réfléchir c'est c'est bien
[Musique]
ben c'est comme si j'avais demande moi
c'est le monde de mes rêves et la
réalité
et quand je réfléchis ce que je fais
c'est que j'essaye de coller les deux
mondes ensemble et d'essayer de
voir ce que ça fait et ça me fait
réfléchir
j'ai vraiment la tête dans les nuages
permanence
et c'est tout ce que je pense toutes mes
opinions
toutes mes craintes et tout ce que
j'aime qui est blotti dans le même monde
un espèce de monde parallèle où il y a
que moi qui peut rentrer dedans
la philosophie ça permet de
de justement parler de nos
notre petit monde parallèle et chacun a
le sien et
je pense que comme moi ça leur fait du
bien de pouvoir en parler ensemble
[Musique]
bonjour
mettez les mains sur vos genoux
on ferme les yeux et on laisse passer
toute la pensée
bon allez c'est fini
alors ça y est il faut ouvrir les yeux
bon bah les enfants moi je vais vous
dire ce que j'ai préféré cette année
c'est de vous rencontrer
j'étais très heureux de vous rencontrer
vous m'avez beaucoup appris parce qu'on
vous écoutant j'ai vu ce qu'il y avait
dans votre tête et c'est vrai des fois
on est très surpris de savoir ce que
vous pensez et c'est pas la même chose
forcément que ce que pensent les adultes
et puis vous êtes très touchant les uns
et les autres j'ai une année super avec
vous donc je vous remercie je vous
remercie de votre gentillesse de votre
accueil d'avoir fait cet effort de
méditer c'est je sais que c'était pas
facile pour tout le monde et puis je
sais que ça a servi à certains j'en suis
heureux et puis j'espère que toute votre
vie vous allez continuer à réfléchir à
vous poser des questions à écouter les
autres à débattre avec les autres parce
que toute la philosophie ça sert à ça
donc je vous souhaite toute votre vie de
continuer à réfléchir et être heureux
merci à tous
au revoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors aujourd'hui j'aimerais qu'on
travaille sur le rapport de l'homme et
la nature et je vais vous poser une
première question pour vous aider un
petit peu dans cette réflexion c'est
est-ce que l'homme fait partie de la
nature ou non Jérémy qui voulait dire
quelque chose on dit qu'on apporte la
nature bah oui qu'on a déjà qu'on
appartient la nature parce que on dit
qu'on allait des descendants des dessins
et depuis que
depuis que l'évolution a évolué c'est
devenu du n'importe quoi
quand on a découvert le feu et tout
après on a on a pensé d'améliorer tout
ça ben en fait ils ont pas amélioré de
la nature ils ont détruite d'accord donc
vous êtes en train de me dire que
l'homme appartient la nature certains
m'ont dit ça et en fait il se comporte
comme si la nature lui appartenait Yanis
moi je me suis dit une fois
qu'est-ce que ça ferait d'être à la
place des animaux qu'est-ce que ça
ferait que nous on prenne la place d'un
animal n'importe lequel au pif et que
l'animal prenne notre peau
et qui font la même chose avec nous
juste tester une année juste tester une
année la moitié serait déjà mort et on
dit on se dirait on se dirait ah c'est
ça que chaque jour les animaux pour
résister à ce qu'on leur fait juste ça
et je pense que là tout le monde
arrêterait tout ce qui est tout ce qui
pourrait la nature par exemple quand on
monte des cartes du monde à nous les
enfants on dit setter appartient à la
CPI ces choses à partir de la saucisse
là ça va mais il est où le lieu qui
appartient à la fin qui est à tout le
monde
à la philosophie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vraiment la philosophie ça m'a aidé à
répondre à mes questions que je me
posais
franchement normalement sans philosophie
et son débat quand on parle à quelqu'un
souvent il te dit que c'est nul ce que
tu dis et que c'est pas vrai alors que
pendant les débats
tu as d'autres opinions et tu te réponds
donc pensez c'est individuel mais quand
on les dit quand les exprime et ben
enfin s'exprimer pendant à travers la
philosophie ça nous aide à voir avoir
les choses autrement avoir les choses
ensemble en groupe
la philosophie elle est partout
et grâce à ses séances là en fait je
comprends que la philosophie c'était pas
juste cette année mais en fait c'est
depuis que je suis né je fais de la
philosophie partout
[Musique]
je pense que la philosophie c'est
vraiment pour faire avancer le monde
quoi donc ce que tu es en train de dire
c'est important c'est qu'effectivement
si les choses vont mal dans le monde
faut peut-être changer notre manière de
penser c'est ça vous êtes d'accord avec
ça alors qu'est-ce que vous voulez
changer dans le monde
qu'il n'y a plus
et que moi
moi ok dernière chose
que les autres le fassent faut pas que
quelqu'un le fasse de connu pour qu'on
le fasse faut pas attendre il faut le
faire
[Musique]